If you do a Syrex array test for food allergies,
are there results forever?
Or can your food allergies change?
So I think I answered that, but I answered again.
No, they're not forever.
Your food allergies can change.
So when you do a Syrex, can let's say,
some can change for the better.
Meaning they will go back to normal range
and then you'll have, and that would be all great.
But that's not just always the case
because when you change your diet, you, okay,
you eat less of what was positive on that test.
Well, you have to eat more of something else.
And the truth is, it's not even if you don't eat
more of something else.
It's because you have a damaged gut.
That's why you have the antibodies in the first place.
So it's gonna take time to heal that damaged gut.
So I do not ever recommend running a Syrex 10,
you know, more than like every six months
because you gotta work on healing your gut.
So when you have a really bad test on that,
let's not like, oh, you're just sensitive
to all these foods you can't eat anything
for the rest of your life.
No, no, no, it's just telling you that your gut is so damaged.
You gotta heal your gut.
So I've had people that had irritable balls
and drilled a Crohn's disease and they tested,
I mean, like everything was, it wasn't like
what you're sensitive to.
It's like, let's count the number of foods
that you can't eat.
So then they would try to eat those foods,
but if you're not healing the gut and call me that,
and call me the immune response style,
you're never gonna get this positive better.
So remember, if you already have self antibodies,
like in the case of Crohn's disease,
they have antibodies to GI tissue.
So they have an autoimmune attack on their epithelial cells.
It's many different,
anybody's the different GI tissues you can have.
And let's say it's the epithelial cells that lie in the gut.
And every time you cause an inflammation in the gut,
you're gonna cause more destruction of self tissue.
So you have to decrease that cause of inflammation.
So it's essential that these people do a Cyrex tend to know
one of the things that I really need to cut out
for a period of time while I'm trying to heal the gut.
When you're dealing with autoimmune disease,
if anybody has studied my course on that,
you'll find out you have to find the triggers.
And many times, food is at least a trigger
that you have to call that down.
So that will change over time.
The more you could heal the gut,
the more that you can make permanent changes for the better.
Now some food is antibodies and antibodies
to certain peptides have been proven over the course
20 years that these tests have been available,
that stick around longer and that one of those is gluten.
So, but I've seen gluten antibodies go back to normal
and I've seen people that have swored up and down
that they don't eat one speck of gluten
and they look at all across the reactants and such,
and they still have gluten antibodies five years
after their initial test.
So, but it seems like other ones seem to dissipate quite quickly.
So that's the good news.